as in direct negotiations continue
between Israel and Hamas in the
alleyways and market stalls of
Jerusalem's Old City one consequence of
the Gaza conflict remains beyond dispute
tourism here has been devastated how
many customers do have at the moment at
the moment 0none my guide to the city
Durrani OSHA runs a small touring
company for those visiting Jerusalem
from near and far during better times
his clientele ranges from day-tripping
Israeli couples to large groups from
China if someone is calling us so we
just want to cancel the latest round of
conflict in Gaza has impacted the entire
tourism trade one of Israel's largest
economic drivers we are talking about
close to 4 million tourists coming to
Israel you have an income of six billion
dollar a year which is very important
for country like us this year instead of
the four million visitors to Israel that
operators expected it's predicted that
number will fall to 2.8 million with
far-reaching effects airlines we've
affected hotels being affected
transportation buses guide restaurant
taxi driver travel agent almost
everybody will be affected somehow but
in Jerusalem's historic center the bells
toll for businesses that belong to both
Israelis and Palestinians so normally at
this time of year you'd have people
everywhere everywhere especially in the
market while Israeli citizens demand
answers from their political leaders
many Israeli workers require assurances
from their bosses they have to show my
employees that they're working in a good
place and I can provide them celery's
and jobs and if some work came I don't
tell them go home you don't have work is
Realtors promised to compensate
businesses that suffer losses because of
the conflict but for many here any loss
of income is nothing compared to the
loss of life we need a propulsion here
there is people suffering a lot more
than us and if you will just have a few
months of quiet
we can reach a stable atmosphere and we
can manage we can manage